[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Dr. Keith
Devlin is a mathematician
at Stanford University.
He has written 33 books and over
80 published research articles.
He's here today to speak
to us about his new book,
"Finding Fibonacci,
the Quest to Rediscover
the Mathematical Genius
Who Changed the World."
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Devlin.
[APPLAUSE]
KEITH DEVLIN: Thank you.
Thank you everyone for coming.
It's nice to be back
at Google again.
It's nice to have sunshine
outside as well, especially
since we had to hike in
from a distant parking lot.
"Finding Fibonacci,
the Quest to Rediscover
the Forgotten Mathematical
Genius Who Changed the World."
It took us six months to
come up with the title.
And I didn't come up with it,
but some marketing person did.
It's actually a book.
It's about a book.
It's about a book about a book.
And it's about a
book about a book
about a book, where the last
one is right associative.
The book that we start
with is "Liber Abaci,"
spelled with double B, and
published in 1202 in Pisa,
in Italy, handwritten
manuscript.
The book that we
now know, thanks
to research that was done
in the early 2000s era,
began the whole of the
modern Western world.
So that was fairly recent.
The book about the book,
where I got involved,
was this book, "The Man of
Numbers," published in 2011.
That was a result
of almost a decade
of research trying to
understand how Leonardo came
to write "Liber Abaci,"
and in particular,
whether in factly that
book was the beginning
of the modern Western world in
terms of finance, and commerce,
and multinational conglomerates,
and yada, yada, yada.
And we've only known
that for sure since 2003.
And then because this was a
very different project for me--
I'm a research mathematician
and all sorts of other stuff,
and for various reasons I
was interested in Leonardo
of Pisa, Fibonacci, the
most significant reason
was that he was an OK ma-- not
exactly a good mathematician,
but he really was famous
for writing books that
were read by lots of people.
And I've spent a lot of
my career writing books
for lots of people, textbooks
and graduate textbooks,
undergraduate textbooks,
general market books.
So in a sense, I've been
following in his footsteps
for a large part of my career.
But because I was going
into the world of history,
and I hadn't done any history
before, I kept a diary.
Because I thought
as much you can,
you just have a record
of the whole process,
because this was new for me.
And I was learning
as I was going along.
And when the book was
published in 2011,
I had this huge diary
with all these notes
that I've been gathering.
And I talked with my
agent, and then we
said, well, we could
turn this into a book it.
Took a long time to get it
done, and then we eventually
pitched it out.
My agent took it.
Princeton University Press
decided to bring it out.
And that was like two years ago.
And it's taken another
couple of years
to actually turn it
into a readable book.
It was just a bunch of notes.
Another book on the way-- there
was actually a fourth book
that I brought out at the same
time as "The Man of Numbers."
it was a sort of a compendium
called "Leonardo and Steve,"
because one of the things
that came very obvious when
I was doing the research
on "The Man of Numbers"
was that the history of
Leonardo and "Liber Abaci"
was exactly the same as the
development of the Macintosh
in the '80s in Silicon Valley.
I mean to the fine details.
In fact, what "Leonardo
and Steve" is,
and it's only in
an ebook version.
We decided since it was about
comparing it with Apple,
it would be only
available in an ebook.
You can get it from
Apple if you want,
or you can get it from Amazon.
What I did was I took Stephen
Levy's book, "Insanely Great"
and basically just replaced
Jobs and Macintosh with Leonardo
and "Liber Abaci," and the
whole thing was the story.
I basically got the story that
was in "The Man of Numbers."
And so I massaged that a
bit and we brought that out.
OK, let me start here,
because I can't tell you
about the new project without
very quickly telling you
about the old project.
Here's the standard
story of how arithmetic
comes into the Western world.
We get Hindu Arabic
arithmetic developed in India
in the early part of the common
term, the first millennia.
Probably the iconic
figure is Brahmagupta.
Then we get al-Khwarizmi in
9th, 10th century Baghdad,
with his books on Hindu
Arabic arithmetic and algebra,
giving us the words algorithm
and algebra at the same time
with those two books.
And then we say Leonardo
learned about that in his youth
from the Arabic texts
and the Persian works
and all of the stuff
that was floating around,
and brought out his book and
the rest was history, we say.
Well, let me just tell you
a little bit about Leonardo.
It's got nothing to do with
the Fibonacci Sequence, which
has almost nothing
to do with Fibonacci.
That was something that was
put in the 19th century.
OK.
Grew up in Piso, father's an
international businessman,
travels to Bugia in North
Africa when he's a teenager.
He's mathematically gifted.
He's arithmetically gifted.
I mean, mathematics was
really arithmetic back then,
a little bit of geometry.
He observed the
Muslim traders, who
were going up the Silk Route
between the Orient and North
Africa, saw them using
this, what we now
know as Hindu Arabic arithmetic,
was very impressed by it.
When he goes back to
Pisa, well, he actually
spends a few years
wandering around
in North Africa around
the Muslim world.
And then, when he gets back,
he writes this mammoth book.
Completes it in 1202,
and it's generally
regarded as being the beginning
of the modern Western world
and the way we live our life.
His real name?
Well, we don't know.
These people didn't have
the same kind of names.
He would have been known later
in life as Leonardo of Pisa
because he became very,
very famous in his lifetime.
He had a name.
He was invited to talk with the
emperor Frederick at the time.
He refers to him in the
book as Filius Bonacci.
It was written in Latin,
handwritten Latin,
so he calls himself
son of Bonacci.
We should maybe translate
it as of the Bonacci family,
because his father
wasn't called Bonacci.
They didn't have names.
They were just names associated
with the groups of people,
with the families.
So it probably means
one of the Bonaccis.
And then that word
Filius Bonacci gets
contracted by a historian
in the 19th century
into the word Fibonacci.
So Fibonacci is
just a name that was
ascribed in the 19th century.
And then the Fibonacci
sequence was actually
coined by the number
theorist Edward Lucar
also in the late 19th century.
So most of what we
associate with Fibonacci
was actually invented by
historians in the 19th century,
including the name of
the Fibonacci Sequence.
The only connection
of that with Leonardo
himself is that one of
the hundreds of exercises
in his books was the rabbit
problem that gives rise
to the Fibonacci Sequence.
But it wasn't
original to Leonardo.
It had been around.
You can trace it way back
to the Hindu mathematicians.
It's been around a long time.
We don't know what
he looks like.
There are two
images you can see.
There's a woodcut, which
you can see photographs of,
and there's a statue in Pisa.
But they're fairly
recent, and so we
can't assume anything
other than the fact
that those pictures are around,
and that picture and statue are
around.
Almost certainly, they're
the just conceptions.
What else do we know?
We know a little bit about him.
Some of this we
didn't even know when
I started my studies,
because some of it was only
found out while I was working.
I was traveling to
Italy every year.
He wrote a bunch
of books, though.
This, by the way, is the
second edition of the book.
The first one didn't survive.
The second one was at
the end of his career,
or at least 20 years later, 26
years later, whatever it is.
And this was an image
that I had taken
from the original manuscript.
One of the nice
things about this,
if you go to Italy,
at least back then,
and you had an association
with a major university,
they'll let you in the archives.
And I sat and had this
copy of "Liber Abaci",
this 13th century copy of
"Liber Abaci", in my hands,
and measured it, and sniffed
it, and did all kinds
of things one might want to do.
But he wrote that second edition
at the end of his career,
when he was a famous person.
Other books he wrote?
He wrote a massive,
massive book on geometry.
He wrote a series of solutions
to problems, challenge problems
that he was given.
They of had a 13th century
version of Jeopardy,
where you go in front of an
audience and you ask questions.
He was probably given
the questions in advance,
but they were tricky
questions and he
gives very brilliant answers.
There was a book on number
theory, elementary number
theory, "The Book of Squares"
about Pythagorean triples.
And then there's a reference
to another book that he wrote,
which was supposed to be
"Liber Abaci for Dummies,"
we might want to call it today.
It was meant to be
a simple version
that the ordinary
traders could read.
And it was probably in
the vernacular of Italian,
but we don't know because
no copies were found.
So that's the standard story.
But there was a
big question mark.
Did Leonardo really
have the influence
that people would
assume that he did?
Well, here was the reason
why they assumed it.
His book appears at the
beginning of the 13th century.
Within the next 30 or 40 years,
coming out of Pisa, Florence,
that general area, we
have modern banking,
we have insurance companies,
we have international trading
empires being run out of Pisa.
We have double entry bookkeeping
coming out of Florence.
All at that time.
So, boy, is there correlation.
The question was,
is that correlation
because of causation?
Was it because
they got his book,
they had access to
Hindu Arabic arithmetic,
and they developed a
whole bunch of stuff?
I'll come back to
that, because that
was what this whole
story was about,
looking in a little bit
more detail what happened
after the book came out.
Within a few years,
you have the beginning
of an enormous number of
handwritten manuscripts
on teach yourself arithmetic,
commercial arithmetic.
They're now called abacus books.
They weren't discovered
until the 1960s,
but there's a lot
of them around.
250 have survived.
We can extrapolate that there
must have been thousands
of these things written,
because these were just
written by people themselves.
If you wanted to learn
commercial arithmetic,
you went to wherever in town
had a copy of a manuscript,
you copied it slavishly,
and then you went home
and you studied it
and worked through it.
That's how they worked.
All of the manuscripts have
this form that there were slave
easily copied,
and then they were
annotated when the people
went through and tried
to learn from them.
And so these were mainly
written for people themselves,
ordinary people
trying to learn it.
If 250 of those have survived
when these were just books
that people had
written 800 years ago,
there's got to have been an
awful lot of them written,
because no one would have
thought or valued them
to the point of trying
try to save them.
There were lots of
schools that were formed.
There was a whole
bunch of activity.
So you've got this
massive amount
of activity taking place,
at the beginning of the--
shortly within a few
decades of the appearance
of "Liber Abaci."
Those are facts.
This is all data.
We've got all of this stuff.
We know that happened.
We also know-- or we
think we know, thanks
to a professor of
finance at Yale,
who would looked
through "Liber Abaci"
and traced back all of
modern finance methods.
And this is a long paragraph.
There's no intention
of you reading this.
It's just to say that we've
got a bunch of stuff now,
and it's all in the book.
It's all in both of
our books, in fact.
He actually went
through and traced back
all of the modern
financial systems
and said there's actually
exercises in "Liber Abaci" that
refer to all of
them, essentially
the beginnings of this stuff.
OK, the doubts were that
there's an enormous difference
between "Liber
Abaci," which we have.
There's for good copies
of it in existence,
and there's another seven
or so in partial existence.
So these, all of these
things were the same.
They were copied
from each other.
They were short books
that were in vernacular
Italian for the most part.
And they all have
lots of similarities.
They copied the exercises.
They updated them.
They changed them
into local currencies.
So there were minor
differences, but they
were all in a clear genre.
The mathematics was
absolutely in here.
But in here, it was in
a very different form.
It was in scholarly Latin.
It was very difficult examples.
It was worked out in the
way of Euclid's "Elements,"
with the axioms and proofs.
This was hard reading.
An average trader wouldn't
have been able to follow that.
So the point was, how did
this material get there?
Either it came from
that book, and someone
did that translation,
more than a translation.
They simplified it grossly.
Or else it came
from another source.
That was the big question.
The clue it turned out
was to look at everything
else he'd written.
Because most of those
abacus books, most
of those commercial
arithmetic books,
they also included a
chapter on geometry.
Well, there was no
geometry in "Liber Abaci".
The geometry was
in this other book.
So that means whoever started
writing the first, whoever
wrote the first of
those abacus books
not only was able to
read and understand
Leonardo's scholarly
tome, "Liber Abaci",
but also read and understand
his other scholarly tome,
"Practical Geometry."
So that's an awful lot of work.
These are 600 or
700 page manuscripts
in dense, scholarly Latin.
Now, either there was
somebody else around,
who was taking that
material and made
it available to
all of the traders
and the ordinary working
people, or else Leonardo did it.
But if there had been
somebody else around,
it's kind of weird
that we haven't
got any manuscripts written
by another great mathematician
of that time.
So there's a lot of
circumstantial evidence
that Leonardo had done it.
And the guess was.
He refers in his
writings to having
written this book
in a smaller manner,
or sometimes called "The
Book for Merchants."
He says that he's written a
smaller version of this thing,
but no copies have been
found, except in 2003,
two years after I'd started
going to Italy on this project,
wondering if I'd
ever write a book,
I got to know the most eminent
scholar about that period
in medieval mathematics,
Rafaella Franci.
And while I was there, she
was making a discovery.
She basically found it.
She found that connection
book, that missing link.
It certainly wasn't written
in Leonardo's old [INAUDIBLE]
we don't know that.
It almost certainly wasn't
written in Leonardo's hand.
There were some silly
math mistakes that
would suggest that was a copy.
But that would mean it
was almost certainly
a faithful copy, because
if you don't understand it,
you don't try to improve it.
You just try to copy it.
So we have something that
looks like that manuscript.
There's the person that
made it, Rafaella Franci.
That's where that
manuscript is now.
It's just up from the
Duomo in Florence,
in a rather interesting library
with a beautiful ceiling, which
took me an awful lot
of trouble to get into.
That's the only known copy.
That is the first popular
arithmetic book in the West.
There's a couple of pages I had
copied from it, images taken.
It was written,
this one, we know
from looking at the currencies,
was written around 1290,
so just after Leonardo had died.
So it was either a copy of his
manuscript or something else.
But by looking at
that in detail,
and doing a bunch
of other analyses,
the conclusion has now
got pretty definite
that it was a copy of the thing
that Leonardo had written.
In the introduction,
he says, the author
of this thing, the
unknown author,
says it's actually written
in the form of Leonardo.
OK.
So now we actually
know what that
must look like,
because this one,
you can clearly trace this
to all of the other ones.
This is the Eve.
This is the Eve book
of those surveys.
This was a copy of something
was written that all
of the other ones came from.
This is really close
after "Liber Abaci".
That was what gave
them material.
And by looking at all
of the circumstances,
we now have historical evidence.
And this is again
just wallpaper.
There's a lot of evidence
because after she
did that discovery, a lot of
scholars started looking at it,
and there's a whole bunch of
studies that have been done,
establishing with
as much certainty
as you're going to get in
history that that question
mark doesn't need to be there.
That is a fact.
It came from him, and
it came from the book
that he wrote for merchants.
Interesting question
shortly after this.
The guy's famous.
All sorts of stuff's going on,
and then he gets forgotten.
Why does he get forgotten?
Technology.
Handwritten manuscripts
became completely irrelevant
the moment the
printing press arises.
It takes a long time to copy
a mathematical manuscript,
but when you put it in typeset,
you can make lots of copies
instantly.
So the moment the
printing press came along,
there were two books that
were printed very early.
One was the Gutenberg Bible.
Another one was a practical
arithmetic book from that canon
of practical arithmetic books.
So the demand was high.
There was immediately
a printed one produced,
but the printed book was
based on these smaller
books for merchants,
not on Leonardo's book.
So by now, Leonardo's book's
200 years old or more.
It's just going to sit
there on the shelves.
No one's going to
look at it anymore,
because the material
is accessible in books.
So he was an early
victim of technology.
The only way we know about
him, because he was completely
forgotten for
hundreds of years, was
that a famous
mathematician, Luca Pacioli,
wrote a printed book called
"Summa de Arithmetica,"
arithmetic, geometry,
proportions, proportionality,
a general book, a scholarly book
but on practical arithmetic.
And he has an
introduction in which he
says he's based it on Leonardo.
And then into the early
late 18th, 19th century,
a historian, a historian
of mathematics,
actually a mathematician who
was interested in history,
is studying this
famous book, sees
this reference to this Leonardo,
and says, hm, who is that guy?
And he digs around, finds
out, and bit by bit,
he uncovers the story.
So since then, we've
known about Leonardo.
So that's what's in
"The Man of Numbers."
What I started to do in
2002, actually in 2001,
but my first trip to
Italy was in 2002,
was to find out that story.
And then that was when I
started writing this diary.
So here's what I did.
First of all, I tried to get
a sense of what life was like.
There was almost no history.
There were no facts.
I had to recreate this.
I actually had to do what that
person did with that engraving
or with the statue.
I had to try and recreate
a model, or an image,
a story of Leonardo that
fitted what facts we know,
and that made sense.
So I did two things.
I read a lot of his
stuff, because you
can get a lot of understanding
of a mathematician
by looking at their work.
And he wrote a lot.
And I also wandered around
Pisa and various other places
to just get a sense of it.
Because this is the part
of Pisa that we all know,
the Leaning Tower, the
Camposantto at the bottom,
and the Baptistry,
and the monasteries.
Whatever you call it, the
monastery, the cathedral.
All of which was there.
Actually, the Leaning
Tower was being built
while Leonardo was a child.
So all of that existed.
It was a port.
It was a port, even though
it's nowhere near the sea.
It's about 20 miles from the
sea, from the Mediterranean.
But it was a port because
flat bottom boats could go
from the Mediterranean shore.
And so Pisa and Florence
were both ports.
They were major trading ports.
Some of the old
buildings, including
one of the old customs houses
where Leonardo's father
would have been working at
some point, they still exist.
So these are all
images I took and tried
to get a sense of the place.
Because this is Italy and no
one knocks buildings down very
often, you can actually see what
kind of place he would live in.
So we have a lot of images.
We can get a good sense of
what life must have been like.
So just by walking around
Pisa and taking photos,
I try to get a sense in my mind
of what the guy was looking at.
We know that he left
to go to North Africa.
He would have gone to
Livorno on one of the ships.
Part of the old
port is still there.
And there's the
new version of it.
So that's now a major,
a major shipping port.
But it was a major shipping port
back in the time of Leonardo.
Leonardo would have gone out
on a dirt road, on a cart.
Now there's a very fast
road that takes you
down there pretty quickly.
And that's what
Livorno looks like now.
Next thing I wanted to
do was find the statue.
That was interesting.
The statue was actually
created not long after people
after that discovery
was made, after Casale
made that discovery of
Leonardo and he became famous,
then Pisa pretty
quickly said, hey,
we've had a famous
guy in our history,
and decided to celebrate him.
They had this statue
made of Leonardo.
That was the statue at the
end of the Second World War
when there had been one hell of
a battle over the bridge here.
That was a photo I took in 2002,
or 2003, of the same location.
The only things that
had been left standing
was that building and that
statue that was in front of it.
Somewhere, I have a photo
of me standing there, trying
to pretend I'm Leonardo.
And I wanted to find it.
And I'd seen pictures
of this thing.
After the second
war, it was moved.
It was just put in storage.
I got references that said it
had been taken out of storage
in 1966 and put in this garden.
And indeed, I was able to
look at photographs of it
in the garden, where it was
obviously a major meeting
point for birds, who would--
I guess it was a gender
neutral bathroom for birds,
I would imagine.
But it wasn't there.
The statue wasn't there.
And so the information I'd
got wasn't very helpful.
So looking at it
a little bit more,
I found references that said
the statue had been moved
into a cemetery near the main
square with the Leaning Tower
and whatever.
But there's only
one cemetery there.
It's a small Jewish cemetery,
and Leonardo was surely
Catholic, so it would
be unlikely he was
buried in a Jewish cemetery.
But that was me peering into
the Jewish cemetery, saying,
is he there?
And then you're walking
around afterwards,
thinking where is this statue?
There was one of these
signs for tourists
that said "Camposanto
the Monumental Cemetery."
So at that point, it
was an aha moment.
Yes, that must be the cemetery.
And indeed, there was
the statue in there.
It's at the end of a
long corridor in a very
splendid position.
It's high profile,
all nicely cleaned up.
A couple of years
later, I had many trips.
I went to look at one of the
other dedications to Leonardo
you'll find there.
There's a commemorative
tablet in this building,
just along from that bridge
where the statue used to be.
And it was a commemorative
tablet put up in 1867.
Again, shortly after
they had rediscovered
their famous person.
And there's this
Latin translation.
I actually learned Latin at
school, but couldn't read this,
because this is classical
medieval marketing Latin, which
is a very weird kind of Latin.
So I got a very famous
Latin scholar in Los Angeles
to do the translation for me.
And that is that translation.
It's in the book.
And that's me sitting
in front of this thing
when I'd finally found it.
Other memorabilia.
So in Pisa, and in
Florence in particular,
there were street
signs dedicated
to Leonardo Fibonacci.
There's a couple of nice ones
on the Lung'arno Fibonacci,
which becomes the Lung'arno
Galileo a little bit further
on.
Florence has a little
street with 11 signs.
There's seven of them.
And there's the rest of them.
So this tiny little street--
it's only a couple of meters
long--
has signs everywhere
to Fibonacci.
It also is the home of the
Italian Computer Society, which
obviously was very, very keen
to get an address on Fibonacci,
not a Fibonacci
number, unfortunately,
but they came close, right?
And then there's
the manuscripts.
I'm going to give you just a
quick look at the manuscripts,
because these are beautiful.
These are handwritten
manuscripts.
There's the library in Siena.
It was at the time of
the Palio, so there
were all of these flags there.
There were a couple of
really crummy pages,
but there are some
beautiful pages.
And these are all images that
I had made of this manuscript.
It obviously had
been worked through,
because there's the text,
and someone had gone through
and done some calculations.
Leonardo himself would put this
kind of thing in the border.
Since this was before
the printing press, what
they did was they
wrote the text in words
together with the
numerals, because words are
self-error-correcting, right?
Humans can error-correct words.
And When these were hand-copied,
errors would come in.
So mathematics was presented
in words with numerals,
because that's a natural
error-correcting system.
The mathematics itself
was put in the margin,
and the author assumed that
that could get badly mangled.
After the printing
press, that flipped.
Mathematics became
symbolic, and the words
were the explanations
of the mathematics.
Whereas before the
printing press,
mathematics was in
words, and the symbols
were an explanation or an
extrapolation from the words.
It's interesting how we
adapt to new technologies.
So there's the Siana manuscript,
some nice images from it.
I got to see the
one in Florence.
There's the entrance
to the library.
Looks a little bit different,
different kind of paper,
parchment.
It's like paper, I
guess you'd call it.
I mean, it's parchment.
Actually, I guess
it's parchment.
It's thin.
It's quite high
quality parchment.
It looks a little bit different.
The colors are a
little bit different,
but essentially the
same manuscripts.
One of the other ones,
the really good one--
there were three
really good ones--
is in the Vatican.
Unfortunately, when I
was doing this research,
the Vatican Library
Collection was closed.
They were renovating.
So I've never yet
got to see that one.
And I want to go and
see that manuscript.
And I'll show you a couple
of pages for the Riccardiana
Manuscript, and
some print versions.
Those are the only known
print versions of this thing.
And we're done.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]